qu'ils mangent et courir ici si c'est
parce un chopper c'est ici c'est le long
du fleuve aucune sur 7 sur 7 b cyclable
qu'on appelle de greenway vraiment
l'autoroute des vélos on peut aller
partout très très rapidement en
empruntant cet esclave et lorsqu'on voit
même s'il ya des terrains de basket ball
a des terrains pour les skate board les
rouli roulant
comme je vous l ai parc pour les enfants
parcourent les chiens donc vraiment une
zone pour les new yorkais qu'elle ignore
qui utilise beaucoup ici la fin de
semaine là surtout qu'on est dans la
période d'entraînement pour le marathon
de new york qui bientôt il ya tellement
joggeurs ses fins de semaine qu'on peut
même pas marcher ici